today we are going to create imaginary
characters and make them dance and we'll
use an AI to greatly improve the details
in lowquality streamed gaming videos and
we will see if it is possible for a
robot to learn to smell spoiler alert
there is a new AI that has no nose and
yet it can still smell kind of now this
is an AI paper from
2016 this is what was possible 8 years
ago you could take a source video of an
amazing dancer and take a video of
yourself moving about and then it would
transfer these amazing dance moves to
you but today not only text to image but
text to video is also getting more and
more available this means that you can
enter a piece of text and out comes a
video of exactly that what's more today
you can do this with free and open-
Source techniques but if that is
possible does that mean that yes yes it
does so now hold on to your papers
fellow Scholars because today we have
come so far you don't even need a video
of yourself just a little stick figure
moving about and one text prompt to
synthesize the video and then a
character of you will start dancing wow
look look at how far we have come in the
last few years these new results are
still not perfect but they are Leaps and
Bounds beyond the Everybody Dance Now
paper and this is not only better but it
also solves a significantly more
difficult problem you see here with your
text prompt you can choose your
background and your attire As You Wish
no video of you is needed but it gets
better if you can use a text prompt you
you can write whatever you want there
even the Moa Lisa or any other character
you can think about a couple years ago
we were happy if we got a text to image
result with this and now we can just
make them up and make them move exactly
the way we want it to absolutely
incredible dear fellow Scholars this is
2minute papers with Dr
carool now I will quickly note that this
paper is a tech report and as of the
making of this video it was not
peer-reviewed yet it just came out a few
days ago and supposedly the source code
and the data sets for creating all this
will also be available now we talked
about a brilliant little paper earlier
where scientists at Nvidia wanted to
create high quality video conferencing
videos by compressing them down far more
than previously thought possible I would
tell you what it does but I will tell
you what it does now not it does not
compress the entirety of the video
information but it only takes the first
image from the video and then throws
away the entire video afterwards what
why well it is able to do it because it
learns about your head movement and
gestures and is able to synthesize that
in a way that is super close to reality
that is fantastic however look
compression arst effects still remain
the lower we go with the bandwidth the
worse it gets and now you can use their
newer technique to eliminate those look
when streaming games or video unless you
have a really fast connection you get
some of these artifacts along these
lines and something perhaps even worse
blocky artifacts but now with these new
super resolution AI techniques ha no
more look at that flag if you wanted to
get this kind of quality you would
either need a significantly more
powerful internet connection to stream
it or an expensive computer to render it
yourself once again no more love it now
not even this technique is perfect its
earlier version was widely tested and
testers typically found it to be working
really well on static and slow moving
content however when used on fast moving
footage it might introduce its own
artifacts now to the best of my
knowledge it is already available on the
RTX 2000 series graphics cards and app
which is fantastic news these are from
an age when these cards were a little
more affordable more longevity for us I
like it note that we do not have any
business ties with Nvidia and now the
ultimate question fellow Scholars we
know that these modern AI techniques
learn to listen see and even talk but
here is a crazy question is it possible
for an AI to learn to smell well this
crazy paper attempts to give this a try
first they give it a bunch of molecule
structures as an input and they get
information on what humans think this
smells like for instance this molecule
smells like a musty research paper with
a hint of caramel and then the goal is
that we give it new compound sounds that
it hasn't seen yet excuse me hasn't
smelled yet so what did it learn well it
learned how we label these smells and
now hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars because when given these new
molecule structures it can tell them
apart at least as well as a human can
that is mind-blowing now just to avoid
any misunderstanding here this is a
piece of software and it does not have a
nose actually ual smelling in a way that
humans smell something does not happen
here it is given a molecule structure
and it makes a prediction based on that
H an AI that has no nose and yet it can
still smell kind of what a time to be
alive when I first heard this I was a
little skeptical but I had a look at the
incredibly thorough evaluation in the
paper and I found that it really knows
which smells typically appear together
and can also put these smells on a map I
think this is an absolutely amazing
concept and with a wonderful execution
as always the link to the paper is
available in the video description if
you're looking for inexpensive Cloud
gpus for AI Lambda now offers the best
prices in the world for GPU Cloud
compute no commitments or negotiation
required just sign up and launch an
instance and hold on to your papers
because with the Lambda GPU Cloud you
can now get on demand h100 instances for
just1 199 per hour yes
$19 and they are one of the first Cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 accs did I mention they also
offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and ctech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lamb.com
papers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today